[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining you suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
and miss wallace and maybe you could
help me out you're stretching in my door
everyone stand down this wall stand down
i won't take such extreme measures this
mission went more important than you
could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team it's okay i'm not
okay each member has chosen for his or
her own
completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a a dog what kind of dog
do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a
werewolf y'all next time
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel
he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but
you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known only
as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the comp
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
edition h
particle security specializing cache
trucks across la
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
yeah we ain't the predators with a prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why
aren't you full of playing pistols in
the machine gun fine do you have a
problem
i don't know do i it's a 10 grand drop
you should have been back five minutes
ago
they're serious leave this to me
get in the truck next time sorry pal
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
a while back we lost two cars civilian
too
there was an investigation we still
haven't found a scam who did it
you were in an accident about my son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
tree has been shook and it's been shook
hard
we've scorched the earth always be a
good boy
you started by certainly do anything
what i'm hearing is
you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job
i can do it in two weeks
you only wish you could do in 20 years
when i do bury grudge
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank everybody
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a goldfish there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules but you are so
much more than that
put these on okay fine oh
my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy there's no easy way to say
this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
please stop
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now that's not real i don't know what it
is i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not going to be the good guy
thanks guys i'm going gonna be the great
guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
off you go this whole good guy routine
is ruining the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mentioned that
that actually hurt my hands we can save
our world
but we have to fight
but i together it
time's up bank teller
[Music]
no
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between
life and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting
two versus one he's gotta be kidding
smoke in the air
oh
[Applause]
i say either just say either
i say neither can i say neither
either neither neither let's
call the whole thing off
catch up excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
he says hi one is the
about you loneliest
you and i are the same
[Music]
every decision we ever make
[Music]
who do we leave behind and how
do we leave them waiting
in the darkness of the rescuer who never
comes
[Applause]
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
soon come chaos
chaos same time
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no no you cannot eat mrs chen what
nothing
on your feet senior chief
john kelly is more dangerous
and effective than any man we have in
the field
the only thing he has more than kills
are medals
somebody would like to talk to you john
if you're done in there
we need you to get back in the field
senior chief kelly it appears you have a
common enemy with the united states
they took everything from me
my family i got nothing left
their plan is a series of strategic
attacks all over the world
we have to respond i need to be on that
team lieutenant commander greer
you lead the mission i'm leaving out the
playing field cia doesn't support any
further investigation into your wife's
murder
[Music]
they know exactly where we've been
what the hell is going on here what's
the real mission
[Music]
then what they want in my house
no remorse
[Applause]
he has had a tremendous year michael
bryce is the bodyguard of the year
[Laughter]
is he a relative of yours god no darius
kincaid's a
hitman wanted for like a zillion murders
around the world and how often do you
have this dream
just once well that's not a night right
i'm thinking you need to forget
bodyguarding
[Music]
i'm officially on sabbatical and to be
honest i don't know why i didn't do this
sooner
[Music]
this is the world's been waiting for me
to make this change
for the first time i'm starting to
imagine a life without bodyguarding
this really feels like a new
psychological orders
that means no guns no killing and no
blood
what is he doing here
are you using pepper spray i'm on
sabbatical
how many times you nearly got me killed
not enough
i would make a great mother don't you
think oh my god a child would be so
lucky to have you as its host
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you
i on the other hand will tell you
everything
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
are you ready to go whatever's on you is
you ready
[Music]
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
[Music]
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
man we messing with magnets now if you
want
and now
you spend the rest of yours
not today
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
[Music]
why'd they put you in a fire tower
well i'm just lucky i guess
i read the wind wrong
[Music]
i should have gone to them
then you've been dead too
that's our job
hey stop i'm not going to hurt you i
want to see where the blood's coming
from it's not my blood
you in trouble
anyone else in trouble
my dad said if anything happened i
should find someone i could trust
are you someone i can trust
we promise absolutes
act accordingly
give them something else to worry about
i'm gonna keep running
you really want to die for this kid
take a deep breath
hold it and lay back
what happens next
[Music]
throughout my life the ten rings
gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
john you are a product of all who came
before you
the legacy of your family you are your
mother
and whether you like it or not you are
also your father
i told my men they wouldn't be able to
kill you if they try
glad i was right
here's just a criminal who murders
people
be careful how you speak to me
i thought i could change my name start a
new life
but i could never escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
you got this
thank right you
well they said kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
we need you to fight
i will be back and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right
yeah going to war stop talking listen
sorry when i'm nervous at talk i'm like
97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future you and your unit
are now
in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster and stronger than you can
possibly imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous i feel like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the base of
the earth
nothing we do here matters that's where
you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit together we
can stop this war
from ever happening this is my
opportunity to give this world a second
chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it
in the cabin the bullet goes in thing
and everybody sucked out
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i mean mistakes choosing between what
the world wants you to be
i know you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world
i'm sorry we had our orders and we
played the
rule it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
[Music]
oh
one thing's for sure
i'm done running for my past
the annual purge will conclude in three
two one
thank you for your participation
we survived all police and emergency
services have been reinstated
all crime including murder is now
illegal come on let's get to work
one night only rest of the year is
peaceful
[Music]
help me help me
the purge is over please
no it ain't this is insane
nobody hear the sirens there's no crime
anymore
anything else you rich can't hide behind
your steel walls no more
powerless how does that feel is the real
purge the forever purge
hurry up they're coming
come on follow me there's nowhere safe
to go
no way to get help oh my god
we gotta find another way to get out of
[Music]
here
this country's gonna collapse
mexico is opening its borders for the
next six hours
we're in this together
does this translate
[Music]
from your secret friend
[Music]
having a clue
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why is he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm
this guy's vengeance
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
the past isn't dead
james fate draws us back together
now your enemy's my enemy
his name is saffin and what does he want
revenge me when our secret finds its way
out
it'll be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play
there's a young lady in santiago i want
you to meet you're late
when you're ready met your new double o
she's a disarming young woman i get why
you shot him
yeah well everyone tries at least once
james bond
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place i just
want to be a little
tidier
come on bond where the hell are you
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these
he's going to days millions
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listening
[Music]
we have watched
unguided we have helped them
progress
[Music]
unseen them accomplished
throughout the years we have never
interfered
until now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
thank you for this oh you are so now
that captain rogers and iron man are
both gone
who do you think's gonna lead the
avengers
i could lead them
this is our only chance
we have to take it
[Music]
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here by the
[Music]
and they're the last ones standing for
greatness
no one
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target had superhuman abilities
[Applause]
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's the birthmark what do you mean he
was born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
world champions that dragon market
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonya
that's kano i'm lou kang
name is jax
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
i am zero
[Applause]
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
[Music]
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other while
we
get rich this is going to be fun
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal civilized
but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
let's end this as gentlemen after all
manners
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see oh
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
is getting a richer one you lose that
one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight like demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
oh man
there they are frank follow me
oh god sorry frank sorry strong form
my name is dr lily houghton my brother
and i are looking for passage upriver
what's out there in the jungle it's not
a fun vacation well i'm not here for a
vacation
legend has it that there is a tree that
possesses unparalleled healing power
it will change medicine forever and you
need someone to help you find it here we
go sometimes it just needs a bit of a
nobody touches my engine but me what did
i just
there you go
we're gonna do this together haven't you
been dreaming about adventure
she was always chasing after some
far-fetched idea
everything that you see wants to kill
you and can
[Music]
do you want to turn back nope just
getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
torpedo michael
i've known you since you were a child
you're a gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly
legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
feel like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
[Music]
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
[Music]
seek shelter immediately what do you
think it is no idea
oh
the only thing people want to talk about
today is this interstellar comet called
clark
nasa's saying it appeared out of nowhere
from like a different solar system
this is the fragment entering the lower
atmosphere three
two one an impact
where's the explosion what's a chunk of
rock rocks don't explode yeah tell that
to the dinosaurs sky's on fire
come on let's go with the largest
fragment expected to hit in less than 24
hours
space agencies are expecting an
extinction-level event
the greatest chance of survival for the
bunkers in greenland
we're gonna go now okay
[Music]
you're such
on demand everywhere december 18th and
initiate sequence
[Music]
gina i'm home memories are
made of this what is this place
i'm sorry to be the one to tell you this
but you got yourself killed
at rsd we'd rebuild the most important
assets in the us military
soldiers like yourself you're the first
who we've successfully managed to bring
back
but improved enhanced with the
technology in your veins
you have an army inside you that will
not only make you stronger
it will heal you instantly
now tell me do you remember anything
[Music]
where are you going i got unfinished
business
oh that's not good
all right sundown
and initiate sequence
okay who is the next target for
elimination
tell me do you remember anything do i
know you guys i don't think so
i've been manipulating you
what you think is real sometimes i ain't
and initiate sequence
[Music]
revenge is what makes a man like you
exceptional you know nothing about men
like me
that is absolutely fantastic
i feel like i just heard this are they
playing with some repeat
not even invited to this thing aren't we
nope
[Music]
uh mom's coming benjamin have you two
been smoking dope
yeah why can't you keep him under
control sons and anarchists mrs given
for generations the given and wrath card
families had
a blood feud it was never about business
your son is trespassing
it was personal marry raskar ben
give it do i need to explain to you why
this is
unacceptable ended
it was an instant scandal
you take care of my problem i'll grant
you my daughter's hand
take care of him looks like man you're
gonna dance
how do you wanna die i wanna die in a
gunfight
the choices they had made had led them
to this very
moment the fallout
it's not gonna be pretty let's get out
of here
i always thought of my life like i was
living my movie
i'm gonna be the star of your movie this
presents me
with an issue keep your friends close
and your enemies close the right dad
enough we're gonna piss a lot of people
off
do you have a death wish something that
excites you
dudes pretty much conform or die
honestly i'd rather die
put the fear of god in they'll try to
stop
us i'll protect you for how long
for as long as you want me to how about
forever
the old wars cold war war on terror
he knew who we were fighting
but now the enemy is invisible they can
destabilize entire countries
from simple reach of their keyboard
[Music]
officially i can't put you on this but
if you were to go out on your own
i would need some help i'm guessing this
isn't a social pool
i'm putting together a team you're the
best in the world of what you do
i thought this was done i'll be back for
dinner tomorrow
[Music]
hands put your gun down please five four
three two
one pull the trigger or you can listen
we all work for different intelligence
agencies
american british german colombian
chinese but now we have a common enemy
and if we don't stop them
let's start world war three
so we need to join forces
this is like half the cia's most wanted
you bump i grab
i like the new team we'll take it from
here
i've got four more agents out on the
street i counted six but thanks for the
tip
i have two children i am a normal person
i cannot do this anymore that guys are
out there right now
you go home you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
we put ourselves in danger
so others aren't
[Music]
[Music]
five
is
[Music]
foreign
foreign
you good girl
you're a dirty little girl
who's in charge here what the hell do
you want at my crime scene or the fbi
i'm with the state police
give me a shout i'm supposed to be
protecting these girls it's not your
operation
you belong to me you understand what i'm
saying
now lift up that skirt no
the minute i got made bait it became my
operation
i have communication with over a dozen
active offenders
we had a bonafide serial killer
i kind of think i'm looking for you
i got a girl with a skull cracked in six
places the bite marks
it matches me another girl vanished
from a truck stop outside pensacola last
night
stop there who's that
get up it's purification time
who was he trying to cuff one of my
girls he had a lightning bolt on his
truck
he's hurting some girl right now
i can set him up again
you sure if you look familiar
i'll never forget such a pretty face
cheers
where is she
folks know you live alone i just want to
keep an eye out for you
you're gonna get me killed we'll have a
little party
don't you worry we'll have our time
together
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
americana
foreign
immediate support
captain do you have any idea what those
markers are they look pretty ancient
the tracks end here it's definitely
bravo team they don't just disappear
oh where the hell are we
that lightning it hit those markers and
it took us somewhere
wow guys
so what are we like guardians of the
galaxy now
on our six dear bros
holy [ __ ]
did you see that thing
this is officially above my pay grade
i don't care what those creatures are
you destroy them and close the gateway
i'm getting us all home
i want you to play a game with me ray i
don't want to play a game oh please
no i said play a game with me raymond
right lovely i want you to imagine
a character your boss mickey pearson
you're too smart to be blackmailing us
fletcher
sweet mary jane is my advice your poison
on the other hand is and always has been
the destroyer of the world
you're out of touch and i would like you
to consider an offer
i am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken
now i can't be specific about the heroes
and zeros
but our protagonist is a hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance stream our antagonist explodes
on the scene like a millennial firework
and has indirectly started a war i think
you need to see this boss
how do they find it i'm making inquiries
his name is for hawk we're spelled with
a p asus how's it going for hawk
please sorry for hold kind of a hawk
if you smell smoke it's because there's
a fire
so you're gonna have to stamp that out
quickly
these people are gonna clean house and
you are part of that house
in the jungle the only way a lion
survived
not by acting like a game
by being the king brilliant
[Music]
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
there's only one rule in this jungle
[Music]
so you killed someone no it was the
gravity that killed him
[Music]
all i have for you is a word
tell it it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
use it carefully
to do what i do i need some idea of the
threat we face
as i understand it we're trying to
prevent world war iii
i'm not saying i'm getting here no
something worse
i gather you have an interest in a
certain
russian national
might bring me in you really want to
know
you can communicate with the future
time travel no inversion
yeah shooting the bullet you're catching
it
well i've seen too much well we'll try
and keep up
your duty transcends national interests
this is about survival
seems bold old i'm fine but i thought
you were gonna say nuts
this is where our worlds collide
how would you like to die old
you chose the wrong profession
[Music]
well happen here hasn't happened yet
there are people in the future who need
us
i need a tenant we need to save them
here and now
this reversing the flow of time
wasn't us being here now and it never
happened
you want to crash a plane we're not from
the air
it's so dramatic
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic
[Applause]
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car
mike we got more time behind us than in
front please cause i'm gonna be running
down criminals till i'm a hundred
girls not me i'm retiring
what happened to bad boys for life it's
time we be good
man
who the [ __ ] wants to sing that song
mike i'll put you on a new team you're
working with ammo now
yeah ammo is a high school musical boy
band with guns
you look great grandpa so you're that
guy there's always one right up till
there's not
that's what i like teamwork
marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you i don't trust a person
that don't want to kill him he'll put my
name up there
thanks a lot we got it marcus we
appreciate it
but family is the only thing that
matters so i'm not letting you go on a
suicide mission alone
one last time one last time
oh get in there's a pimple
let's go come on
oh this is my wife's car give me the
front door
she knows she always knows
[Applause]
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived it's because
you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got
hurt roberto
my girlfriend a partner
diliana i killed 18 men one
by one
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
and makes you live through it until it
kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
can i help you why yes yes you can i'm
here to report a terrible crime
and what terrible crime is that
this one ah [ __ ] i told this all wrong
quick history lesson this all started
when the joker and i broke up
it was completely mutual
and soon enough i was back on my feet
ready to embrace the fierce goddess
within
it's oh so quiet now that i cut ties
with mr j
i'm about to learn that a lot of people
want me dead uh
hello and at the top of that list is
this guy
um but it turns out
[Music]
that wasn't the only damon gotham
looking for emancipation
he's after all of us the kid just robbed
him
you betrayed him you killed his bff
what you are so cool
you never [ __ ] you're dumb enough to
be building a case against him
so unless we all want to die very
unpleasant death
we're gonna have to work together sure
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah are we ready
turn it up
oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bathtub i
named him bruce after that hunky wayne
[Music]
guys
i'm moving the asset we go now
get down
we lost the osprey extraction
we have the governor's daughter i
promised i would keep her safe
we've militia group in close proximity
they will come for us i wonder what this
place is
no one here okay but where did they go
looks like the driver was cut up and
dragged out about what
he's torn to pieces
some lions go rogue
she likes to kill how do you know it's a
she
[Applause]
[Music]
do you want to take a stand here
you can finish this
[Music]
good evening
[Music]
oh wait you're just a civilian now
mr james ford general ronald's
requesting your
inimitable counsel no
he's offered to reinstate you
[Music]
from the top four hours ago the crew the
vander made first contact
stay there
they believe we're hostile
in the event of first contact humanity
must strike first
to ensure the continued survival
of our species operation cosmic sin
is now a go not there
because of space gate they can bring
their army here
what's the status of the cuba if we want
to launch the cue bomb
we need to get into orbit suit's up
that's something huh we didn't know
whether to burn it we put in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me
if we leave that door open we're gonna
charge in
we can make this the kill box
i'm not gonna wait for them to bring the
fight to us
we're gonna take it to them what we do
here
is easy
the hard part is living with it
[Music]
[Music]
you just saw me
[Music]
back
[Music]
sports
my
me
specific
let's go
okay
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i've lost my influence maybe it's time i
retired the coat
and you still have it some kids with a
deer rifle put two holes in the sleigh
wanting me
all i have is a loathing for a world
that's forgotten
the united states military would like to
procure your services this is a one-time
deal gentlemen
how are you mike nicole and the kids are
well i hope
where are you
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i'm looking for the fat man you can't be
serious
this is what people actually think about
christmas is a farce i am a joke
what's the purpose of your visit hunting
i'm gonna kill some things
there is a rising number of our youth
making poor decisions
what the big man's head severed heads
rot they mold and i want his beard
i'm not shaving off a dead man's beard
your workers sure have healthy appetites
that's why elves live much longer than
humans
and chris he knows the same
no it's a giving that keeps him young
[Music]
you think you're the first
i think i got this job because i'm fat
and jolly guys
[Music]
the fat man's got his eye on you kids
like it wasn't blitzer should tear your
package clean off
what i'm about to show you
has only been known to a handful of
people
[Music]
even less have ever seen this
this is project rainfall
well they don't prepare for war right is
their technology integrated with ours
it's a beautiful thing
i've hidden from this war long enough
i'm going to make sure you complete your
mission
you are surrounded you cannot
win oh that's not good
here we go
i'm with you it's not all the times that
we fall but that we rise again
every single time
what else you got
call him as you see him
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
get ready
[Applause]
so
ah
[Music]
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
[Music]
all right we're gonna do this let's do
[Music]
this
on a scale from one to ten how bad's my
rig
we drilled to the bottom of the ocean
and we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how do we even
get there
we walk up we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
oh is that turn your lights off
what is that what is that
what is happening
there's something following us
[Music]
sir we've landed are we still in all go
we're dropping a secret team of robots
into a country that we're not supposed
to be in it got serious the moment was
thought up
sign up you're all gone well i'll kill
you
do it
these people have seen everything take
them all down no witnesses
do you have an id on him yet sending you
a packet special forces huh
this guy is a deserter it could be the
ultimate field test yeah i was thinking
the same thing
she's a doctor they're all doctors
they're here in a good cause mission
come on man okay you're scaring her
you're scaring me i'm scared
find me like a man come on
you were made by humans to affect them
we're different i'm a man i have life
you're a machine
[Music]
[Music]
you